let's see I guess she gets that she gets  a choice ah she should get a choice  after he went on Howard Stern and said  this my free passes because her and  Susan are such good friends is Paltrow I  got to get her back in these movies so I  can make out with her on screen again  Susan we got your back we made Robert  pick your free pass out of this group of  his co-stars  I'm gonna go Bettany get that European  British Flair well fans made a clear  choice to see this cast in action this  weekend Captain America Civil War just  broke fandango's pre-sales record as the  top reselling superhero movie of all  time  all time oh no way this cast did put in  the work criss crossing the globe to do  press but who's the most difficult to  travel with oh I don't fly with any of  those guys probably me I just have a lot  of demands food a train of steamer  trunks a monkey I travel with a live  monkey I would think I think they would  probably say it was me